good morning believe nation today's
message is be your own person over to
you Peter Thiel
you are the entrepreneur of your life
and you can you can you can decide you
know what you're gonna do what you're
gonna prioritize and you should never
forget that you have a tremendous amount
of freedom as it is to make these very
basic decisions on what you're gonna do
with your life and even start you can
start anytime you want so this is a
great message and I think as
entrepreneurs we like to look up to
others we like to model success and it's
something that I encourage as well you
find people who you look up to look at
what made them successful try to apply
that to your own business but along that
way as well you have to discover who you
are and make it your own you can't just
copy exactly what work for somebody else
you've got to take that information
apply that strategy make it your own
digest it and then put it out and that's
we're gonna get success so here's an
example when I was doing my media
training for this channel right to make
me better on YouTube my agent gave me
training on going every week to get
better and at first they told me what to
do do this do this do this give me
specific instructions tell me a
vulnerable story look at this person and
copy their mannerisms showed me some
empathy say things like I know what
you're thinking raise the stakes tell me
all these specific things that I had to
do and almost every time I did them I
felt uncomfortable I felt like it was
definitely a direction in the direction
forward was it was the right path but it
wasn't quite me I had to internalize it
understand what the strategy was and
then make it my own and then that led to
a big jump forward so you know I'm
struggling along here and then I get the
advice and I get a little bit better and
sometimes I might even get a little bit
of worse because I am trying to do
something that I'm not comfortable with
then I internalize it I make it my own
and that's when the lift happens and so
you have to remember that you need to
live your life need to build your
business you need to do something that
you are passionate about excited about
because if you're not you know
gonna have success and so yes listen to
some advice yes ma no success yes look
at people who have done well and see how
you might feel apply that to your
business but at the end of the day you
are your own entrepreneur you are your
own making you've got to do the thing
that makes you come alive and makes it
personal and human because that's the
person that your customers are gonna
connect to and the more you're feeling
it the more your team you're gonna feel
it can where your customers are gonna
feel the more the meeting is gonna feel
like that's what's gonna make everybody
from a lot it's a good luck
so my question today for you guys today
is I want to know how you took somebody
else's advice or how you modeled
somebody and made that strategy your own
how you crafted it too that it fit with
your personality in your style leave it
in the comments below I'm really curious
to find out thank you guys so much for
watching I hope you have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning
for another shot